quatrième morceau c'est un morceau très
difficiles du répertoire américain du
répertoire western alors je ne pouvais
pas le jouer au sol j'ai fait appel à
quelques virtuose de l'harmonica qui ont
composé ce soir et une fois seulement
pour ce palmarès
un orchestre l'ensemble des têtes de
bois
les voici enfin entrer et les voici à
nico ries france à la mort dit luc je
pense
d'abord d'abord comme à l'opéra
nous nous accordons
cela serait très bien attention nombre
comme but qu'on prend comme ça c'est
tout frais comme ça tombe bien la boule
bien le dire des jalons la proposition
3 4
m
c'est un ami dans la vie
nous avons étudié un arrangement spécial
qui va vous permettre d'apprécier le
talent de certains des plus de bruit de
notre liste à trois dimensions
eh bien je suis heureux de jouer pour la
france pour ma famille et pour mon ami
daniel
à
moi
annie cordy la licorne
bon c'est pas malin pour qui tu joues tu
sois bon moi je vous fais c'est de jouer
pour moi amélie marant à bamoro
d'anomalies ainsi le devança le virtuose
international de l'harmonica basten
collège et les moustaches qui se passe
là pourtant pas tellement une tête de
breton je ne pars tour dans une défense
solide à l'entente sur les gens
commençaient
voilà mon pronostic
quand même bien servi bien cherché
dégraisser avant de terminer les salons
de l'arrangement des finales en deçà de
sa femme n'est pas tenue la dernière
vous faites bon dans tout ça c'est
promis
alors vous me faites en inspirant
vengeresse le pouce non en inspire
d'abord ensuite on sait que mon voeu
vois bien un coup n'importe quoi maurice
c'est normal quand on y va
un premier report
avec les peurs
formidable connaissent les paroles à un
ou des paroles c'est ça c'est encore une
fois grâce à une passe à mametz voilà
100 nature et d'ailleurs non non vous
entendez cha cha cha avec nous un récit
on y va on veut pas ça veut dire ça tape
ça elle dit transnationales vous emmène
en tournée à port vila
attention sortie de scène on veut nous
vendre comme des professionnels
attention à gauche
oui tu donnes sans merci oui je le pense
à gauche blanche
j'aimerais bien rester à la soirée pour
faire marcher au pas je vous fais le
roulement des tambours à la rojita